This lecture is about a probabilistic
retrieval model.
In this lecture, we're going to
continue the discussion of tax
retrieval methods.
We can do look at the another kind of
very different way to design ranking
functions than the vector space model
that we discussed before.
Being probabilistic models, we define
the ranking function based on the
probability that this document is
relevant to this query.
In other words, we introduce a
binary random variable here.
This is the variable R here.
And we also assume that the query and
the documents are observations from random
variables.
Note that in the vector space model we
assume they are vectors, but here we
are assumed.
We assume they are the data observed
from random variables.
And so the problem of retrieval now
becomes two estimated.
probability of relevance.
In this category of models there are
different variants.
The classical problem is model has led
to the BM 25 retrieval function which
we discussed in the vector space model.
Because it's a form is actually similar
to objectives space model.
In this lecture, we will discuss another
subclass in this.
Big class.
Called a language modeling approaches
to retrieval.
In particular, we're going to discuss
the query likelihood retrieval model.
Which is one of the most effective
models in probabilistic models.
There is also another line called a
divergent from randomness model which
has led to.
The PL-2 function.
It's also one of the most effective
state of the other travel functions.
Inquiry likelihood
Our assumption is that this probability
of relevance can be approximated by the
probability of query given a document
and relevance.
So intuitively this probability.
Just captures the following probability
and that is if a user likes document D.
How likely would the user enter query Q
in order to retrieve documenting?
So assume that the user likes D.
Because we have a relevance value here
and then we asked the question about
the how likely will see this particular
query from this user.
So this is the basic idea.
Not to understand this idea, let's take
a look at the general idea or the basic
idea of probabilistic retrieval models.
So here are listed at some.
Imagine the relevance of status values
or relevance judgments.
Often queries and documents.
For example, in this line it shows that
query one.
is
A query that the user tightly and the
D1 is a document the user has seen and
one means the user thinks the one is
relevant to Q1.
So this R here can be also
approximated by the click through data
that a search engine can collect by
watching how you interact with the
search results.
So in this case, let's say the user
clicked on this document, so there's
one here.
Similarly.
The user clicked on D2 also, so
there is 1 here.
In other words, D2 is assumed to be
relevant to Q1.
On the other hand, D3  is non
relevant.
There's a 0 here.
At the voice down relevant and then
D5 is again relevant.
And so on so forth.
And this part.
Maybe data collected from a different
user.
So this user typing Q1 and then found
that D1 is actually not useful.
So divine is actually non relevant.
In contrast here we see it's relevant.
And all this could be the same query
typing by.
The same user at different times.
But D2  is also relevant, ET
cetera.
And here we can see more data.
Then what about other queries?
Now we can imagine we have a lot of
such data.
We can ask the question, how can we
then estimate the probability of
relevance?
Right, so how can we compute this
probability of relevance?
Or intuitively that just means?
If we look at the all the entries where
we see this particular D and this
particular Q, how likely will see a one
on the third column?
So basically that just means we can
just collect those accounts.
We can first count the how many times
we have seen Q&D as a pair.
in this table and then count how many
times we actually have also seen one in
the third column.
So and then we just.
Compute the ratio.
So let's take a look at some specific
examples.
Suppose we're trying to compute this
probability for D1D2 and D3 for Q1.
What is the estimated probability?
Now think about that.
You can pause the video if needed.
Try to take a look at the table.
And try to give your estimate of the
probability.
Have you seen that if we are interested
in Q1 and D1 will be looking at
these two pairs?
And in both cases.
Actually, in one of the cases.
The user has said This is why this is
relevant, so R is equal to 1 in only
one of the two cases.
In the other case it's 0.
So that's one out of two.
What about the D1 and D2?
They are here.
in both cases.
In this case R  is equal to 1, so it's
two out of two.
And so on, so forth.
So you can see with this approach, we
can actually score these documents for
the query, right?
We now have a score for D1D2 and D3.
For this query we can simply rank them
based on these probabilities, and so
that's the basic idea of probabilistic
retrieval model, and you can see it
makes a lot of sense.
In this case it's going to rank D2
above all the other documents, because
in all the cases when you have seen D1
and D2.
Eyes equals one the user clicked on
this document.
So this also.
Should.
Show that with a lot of click through
data, a search engine can learn a lot
from the data to improve their search
engine.
This is a simple example that shows
that with even a small number of
entries here we can already estimate
some probabilities.
These probabilities would give us some
sense about which document might be
more relevant or more useful to a user
who typing this query.
Now of course the problems that we
don't observe all the queries and all
the documents and all the relevance
values.
There will be a lot of unseen
documents.
In general we only collected data from
the documents that we have shown to the
users.
There are even more unseen queries
because you cannot predict what queries
would be typing by users.
So obviously this approach won't work
if we apply it to unseen queries or
unseen documents.
Nevertheless, this shows the basic idea
of problems control model and it makes
sense intuitively.
So what do we do in such a case when we
have a lot of unseen documents and then
some queries where the solutions that
we have to approximate in somewhere,
right?
So in this particular case code query
like whole retrieval model, we just
approximate this by another conditional
probability.
P of Q given D an R is equal to 1.
So the condition part.
We assume that the user likes the
document because we have seen that the
user clicked on this document.
And this part shows that we're
interested in how likely the user would
actually enter this query.
How likely will see this query in the
same role?
So no data here.
We have made an interesting assumption
here.
Basically, we can do assume that
whether the user types in this query
has something to do with whether user
likes the document.
In other words, we actually make the
following assumption.
And that is a user formula to query
based on an imaginary relevant
document.
If you just look at this is conditional
probability.
It's not obvious we're making this
assumption.
So what I really meant is that.
To use this new conditional probability
to help us score, then this knew
conditional probability will have to
somehow be able to estimate this
conditional probability without relying
on this big table.
Otherwise we would be having similar
problems as before an by making this
assumption, we have some way to bypass
this big table and try to just model
how the user formulates the query.
OK, so this is how you can simplify the
general model so that we can derive a
specific Iranian function later.
So let's look at how this model work
for our example, and basically what we
are going to do in this case is to ask
the following question which of these
documents is most likely the imaginary
relevant document in the user's mind
when the user formulates this query.
So we ask this question and we quantify
the probability and this probability is
conditional probability of.
Observing this query if a particular
document is infected, imaginary
relevant document in the user's mind.
Here you can see we compute all these
query likelihood probabilities.
The likelihood of queries given each
document.
Once we have these values, we can then
rank these documents based on these
values.
So to summarize, the general idea of
modern relevance in the probabilistic
model is to assume that we introduce a
binary random variable R here, and
then let's a scoring function be
defined based on this conditional
probability.
We also talked about the approximate in
this by using the query likelihood.
And in this case we have a ranking
function that's basically based on the
probability of a query given the
document, and this probability should
be interpreted as the probability that
a user who likes document D would pose
queria Q.
Now the question of course, is how do
we compute this conditional
probability?
At this, in general has to do with how
to compute the probability of text,
because Q is attached.
And this has to do with.
Model called the Language model and
this kind of models are proposed to
model text.
So more specifically, we would be very
interested in the following conditional
probability as issuing this here if the
user.
This document how likely the user would
oppose this query.
Ann
In the next lecture working through,
give an introduction to language models
that we can see how we can model text
with the probabilistic model in
general.